As I was about to leave for a new place, I felt lonely, so I
went to the pet shop, but I'm glad I did.
What name would I like? I'm the
sage of the stars, the door to Piercarlo's remains. I'm a nice
guy who talked a lot, so I'm not happy about it.
I guess my face
looks a little scary.If that's the case, then the contract is complete.What's this?I'll
give you a part of my power.This is it.Ah, this is the
world I lived in until I was reborn in this form.  It's a town like this, so it's a so-called different
world, so let's
go. What kind of ability are you, Sasa-kun?
This is great. Depending on how you use it, it
won't have a big impact on our lives.
Master Sage of the Stars.  I'm trying my best. I'm
not interested in greeting you, old man. I
thought the slow life in the world was just beginning.